I should mention that the chairman of
our board bill brought back is here
today with his wife Jan dr. Jan Palach I
could they stand up please
and also our trusty former governor of
Nebraska kaor is here today stand up
Kate today for the first time in history
we have governors of Nebraska running
out our ears
I've long grown accustomed to living my
life under the command of eighteen year
olds and as my age increases in my time
here increases I've come to see that
after they grow up they still order me
about all the time and that explains
governor Ricketts presence here today
apart from his good nature we have about
four thousand kids here next we have
about 45 kids here from Nebraska at any
given time and they're a very
distinctive as far as we can tell the
only reason anybody ever leaves Nebraska
has to come to Hillsdale College and
that great strings of them have come
from Tabasco including from the family
of gather governor or whose
grandchildren all come here there are
three of them in my line of sight two of
them in my line of sight right now and
two of my former students work in the
governor's office and they started
telling me a few months ago that this
guy is really great and that's a high
standard around here because we believe
in limited government and that's in
short supply in America today no no he's
really great most recent when the senior
one is Taylor gage over there and most
recently Luke Robson student last year
of mine and there's a they're both
pretty smart although you can't tell it
by looking at them
and so they mobbed up with Michael 2kz
and some other people and they presented
me with the fact that governor Ricketts
is coming and I thought okay I guess I
should look this guy up now and what do
I find well first of all he comes from
an entrepreneurial family and he's
worked in the great businesses founded
by that family TD Ameritrade the largest
business probably but also famously the
Chicago Cubs and I'm a radical baseball
fan and so I do believe very much that
it's unconstitutional for the Red Sox to
win the World Series because they traded
the babe and there's no forgiving that
but the Cubs didn't really do anything
that bad there's a various stories to
explain why they lost for more than a
century but they stopped when his family
took over and I've talked to the
governor's father once and I've talked
at length to his brother recently and I
find that one of the reasons that they
were able to turn that team around and
make themselves beloved in that city is
because they're people of real ability
but also such good character they are
giving people they are friendly people
they are well-meaning people they are
energetic people and they're tough as
you have to be to be a governor of a
state this particular governor is
getting the government under control I
questioned Luke Robson who stopped by my
house uninvited as they do around here
to talk to me about all of this just to
make sure I was gonna do a good job and
I questioned the governor's resume and I
said okay he's cut the rate of growth of
the government of Nebraska by 90% what
is it now 25% and he said no he said
it's lower than the rate of inflation
now that is breathtaking in this day and
age and that requires skill and
toughness and conviction
and since this governor is a highly
successful businessman there's no reason
he needs the grief that comes with that
and yet he doesn't even see it as grief
remarkable man I'm proud to present to
you the governor of Nebraska Pete
Ricketts
[Applause]
no government ever voluntarily reduces
itself in size government programs once
launched never disappeared actually a
government Bureau is the nearest thing
to eternal life we're ever gonna see on
this earth many of you recognize that as
a quote from Ronald Reagan talking
directly at the topic of our discussion
today around taming the Leviathan
reducing the size and scope of
government but before we get into that I
want to thank dr. Arnn and the members
of Omicron Delta Kappa for inviting me
to be here today
it's an especial honor and privilege for
me because as dr. Ahn was describing
there's a lot of connections between
Hillsdale College and Nebraska as he
mentioned we actually Nebraska is at the
third largest contingent of students
here despite the small population of our
state we also have the connection that
one of the alums from Hillsdale
preparatory was actually governor of
Nebraska back in the early 20th century
and Supreme Court justice we've got at
least one sitting state council member
city of Kearney who's a Hillsdale alum
and of course as dr. Arnn mentioned our
governor or was also on your board of
trustees and she's a mentor of mine so
there's a lot of connections there and
so it makes it a special privilege for
me to be able to be here and talk to you
about this very important topic
taming Leviathan and that really gets
that the struggle that we got here in
the 21st century that we've been having
for a number of years about the size and
scope of government how do we grapple
with this now when Hobbes wrote the
Leviathan back in 1651 he was actually
writing in defense the monarchy and in
his view the Leviathan was this big
government that was going to protect our
and for the common good and I think it's
kind of ironic because if we think about
Alafia leviathan well Leviathan comes
from the Bible right and it is the sea
monster
that's something you fight against
you're scared of and of course that's
the way that us as conservatives we feel
about the growth of government now this
is not something new when Thomas
Jefferson wrote nearly 230 years ago he
said the natural course of things is for
Liberty to yield and for government to
grant gained ground or said another way
by Ronald Reagan as government expands
Liberty contracts but our founders I
think would be surprised by the
conversations we are having today the
debates we're having remember the
founding of our republic they were
debating whether or not they should have
a standing army or if the government
should be allowed to enforce the payment
of taxes it's a very different
conversation we're having today about
the size and scope of government and in
fact for most of our history as a
country most of the governing was done
at the state and local level which we as
conservatives appreciate because we
believe that government closest to the
people is going to be the most
accountable be the most responsive but
then in the middle of the twentieth
century we had the New Deal and World
War two now up until that time most
Americans didn't really have that much
interface for the federal government
except maybe the post office or if there
was a war but starting in 1940 most of
the spending in our country started to
happen at the federal government before
then it was all done the state and local
level but in 1940 it started going the
wrong way and it's gone the wrong way
ever since so we as conservatives have
been thinking about how to restrain that
how do we slow that growth down and
we've had a number of different
strategies to be able to try that some
of them have been successful you think
back to the welfare reform in the 1990s
which by I might point out started in
the state state of Wisconsin
some that have not been successful
George Bush tried to reform Social
Security that didn't work out so well
we've tried to actually reform
entitlements by creating Thailand
something and Medicare Part D and that's
problematic because anytime you create
an entitlement
you've create a constituency replete
with lobbyists that are there to support
it that's why it's so difficult to get
rid of them we've also tried to restrain
the spending through things such as you
know the budget cap don't borrow any
more money and frankly every time that
happens we create a crisis and we lose
in the court of public opinion now this
doesn't mean we should give up that we
should stop trying to figure out how we
restrain the growth of government but it
does mean that we've got to rethink our
strategy for how we as conservatives are
gonna win this battle in fact I would
say we don't really even have a clearly
articulated strategy for how we're going
to do this so we've got to rethink that
and I'm going to give three things that
we can do in that battle to control
government spending the first of which
we need to continue to look for ways
that we can rethink entitlements the
second is we need to focus when we are
the governors well we're in power as
conservatives we've got to make sure
government is working for the people
third we've got to support the voluntary
organizations in our society that really
strengthen the fabric of our society and
I'll get into each one of those and talk
about why they're so important let's
start with the first with entitlements
now the CBO has said that by 2030 116
years away I plan on being around I know
the young people are still gonna be
around here this is not very far away
for the folks who are in college that
probably seems like a long time 16 years
but when you get to be and I
I'm older than Doug I'm 53 now that's
not very far away 16 years between
entitlements the spending of the federal
government does on health care and the
debt that will take up the entire budget
the entire budget that means nothing of
what the proper functions of government
are like say the defense national
defense or infrastructure that'll all be
crowded out and that's why we have to
focus on how we rethink we talk about
entitlements and I'm in two ways that we
should focus on that first of all
whenever we're talking about
entitlements we should think about what
is the actual goal for the entitlement
what are we trying to accomplish and the
second of all we should push that
responsibility down to the states so
that they can manage it we've done this
in Nebraska we've started rethinking
about entitlements and how we implement
them we've rethought that by really
looking at what is the goal so for
example in our Department of Labor we
have an unemployment program well what's
the goal in unemployment program it's
not just to pay people money the money
the goal is to help people get a job and
so we've changed our unemployment system
into a first-in-the-nation reemployment
program and by that I mean everybody's
seeking those benefits has to sit down
with a jobs coach first before they can
collect those benefits get coaching on
how they find their next job have to
create a resume and that resume is
searchable online so that companies can
proactively reach out to that person and
say hey you've got the job skills I need
what you think about coming and taking
this job by focusing on the goal which
is really to help somebody get their
next job we've been able to reduce the
amount of time people are unemployed in
fact we reduced the number of benefits
the week's benefits claimed by 20% we've
reduced the amount of people reaching
the end of their benefits by over 30%
we've been able to reduce the amount of
claims that we paid out last year by
nearly 14 million
and that allowed us to reduce our
unemployment insurance tax this year by
25%
and we project that'll save Nebraska
businesses seventeen point six million
dollars this year folks that's a
win-win-win it's a win for the person
who's looking for a job it's a win for
the employers who need people to be able
to grow and it's a win for the taxpayer
because we're paying out less in
benefits we're actually shrinking that
entitlement we've got another program
again leveraging the same idea around
our SNAP program the supplemental
nutritional assistance program or
commonly called food stamps and what
we've done there is said what is the
goal well the goal is again is not just
to send out money but the goal is to
help that family feed themselves and the
best way the most sustainable way for
family to take care of themselves if
they can do it because they had a good
job so we've broken down the barriers
between our Health and Human Services
and our Department of Labor and we ran a
pilot in Grand Island Nebraska where we
had the Department of Labor go work with
our families on snap voluntary program
to help them get better jobs and about
half the families we were able to help
do that in fact on average we raised
those families we were able to help we
raise their annual income by sixty nine
hundred dollars one woman in particular
was a single mom working you know hourly
jobs making about nine hundred bucks a
month your regular hours no pension no
benefits we helped her get a job paying
twenty seven hundred dollars a month
with benefits potential for bonuses and
a pension and even more importantly
regular hours so she could be home at
night with her kids
I can folks that's a win-win and what
we've done is we've been able to reduce
those family's reliance on snap in fact
some of them got off at entirely by
rethinking about what are we actually
trying to accomplish well we're trying
to help those families take care of
themselves it's not just about sending
out money and if we can allow states to
continue to innovate them push that
responsibility down to the states we'll
see more in
evasions like we're doing in Nebraska
and what may work in Nebraska may not
work in New Jersey and vice versa that's
why we want the states to do this that's
one of the things we've if we really
want to tackle this problem of
entitlements we've got to take that
responsibility out of Washington DC push
it back to the States let the states
innovate and fit and rethink what our
goals are you know it's important as
well from another standpoint we had the
whole debate in Nebraska about Medicaid
expansion and we are not an expansion
state and one of the arguments we were
able to successfully use was that look
Medicaid is designed for children
elderly the disabled if you make it
about able-bodied single adults you are
taking away from this population the
children the disabled the elderly who
truly need our help you're diluting the
message what Medicaid is about and that
was one of the arguments that helped us
prevent us from expanding Medicaid in
our state so focused on what the
entitlements are about give the
responsibility back to the states second
thing when we are governing when
conservatives are the ones running the
government government we've got to make
sure it runs really really well we've
got to focus on making it run like a
business in fact I believe that's one of
the reasons why the citizens Nebraskan
hired me as governor because I promised
to run government more like a business
now I got a lot of criticism some people
said well government's not a business
camera like a business well it's true
that government is not a business we're
not for profit but we have we provide
services we have expenses and frankly
there are four things in common to any
organization that is going to be
successful whether you're a private
sector for-profit business a non-profit
a government or even a baseball team and
that's you got to have a vision for what
you're going to do you have to
evangelize that vision both inside and
outside your organization so that
everybody knows what your organization's
about you have to get the best people
available to run that organization
and you have to hold him accountable for
results and let me tell you folks that
doesn't happen very often in government
I can tell you from my experience when I
walked into the governor's office we
didn't have basic things like job
descriptions or annular views we
collected lots of data but use none of
it to set goals to hold people
accountable we thought had lots of data
but no measurements but when I applying
those things to running government we've
actually seen tremendous impact on how
we provide our services and we're
bringing a crucial theme that is very
foreign to state government which is you
can deliver great services and control
your costs at the same time now in the
real world you have to do that every all
the time right private sector companies
if they're not figuring out how they can
do a better job serving their customers
and bringing their cost out the same
times they're going to go out of
business well nobody's gonna put the
government out of business which is why
we have to drive this from the top down
from the governor's office on through
all organizations and I'm leaving just a
couple of examples of how we've we've
been able to do this or what we've done
we put everybody in my organization
through Lean Six Sigma white belt
training 12,500 people to let me know
why do we do process improvement why do
we treat people like customers and I
just go back to that SNAP program the
supplemental nutritional assistance
program we have an 800 number that
people sign up for that in August of
2014 before I took over it was taking us
nearly 24 minutes on average to answer
that phone call he was taking us 40 days
to process those applications but by
focusing on process improvement not
adding more money to the budget just
doing a better job what we were doing
streamlining those taking out the
useless complexity getting rid of the
waste we set a goal of 5 minutes or less
to answer the phone we've hit it at 17
out of 19 months we set a goal of 10
days or less to process those
applications we've hit that 14 out of
last 18 months and here's the deal we're
changing that philosophy that mentality
in government because before everybody
thought we'll the only way you can
improve services if you spent more money
and we're showing no you can
to improve services while you spend less
money because as dr. Arnn said we cut
the budget in my first cut we budget we
cut the growth rate from six and a half
percent almost in half and now we cut to
that point six percent so we're doing a
better job at delivering services not
only in Health and Human Services but in
things like issuing tax credits back to
people with permits all these processes
can be improved we're doing a better job
of delivering on those even though we
are cutting the budget and that's the
important mind shift that we've got to
have when we're governing that we can do
a better job delivering services and
reduce our costs because here's the deal
folks people don't want no gun people
don't want no government very few people
want no government there's some adieu
but what people are frustrated by is the
government doesn't work and if we can
show that government can work we can
serve the people and control costs will
keep getting sent back to keep doing it
so that's the second thing and the third
thing has to do with voluntary
organizations voluntary organizations
are fundamental to who we are as
Americans it is part of our heritage and
our legacy as Americans and it's
important for two reasons one it's going
to help us be able provide for the
people truly need our help in society
and it's a part of maintaining our
unique system of self-government on that
first part it's important because we in
government we do provide a lot of
important services we build roads that
people go to see their families on go to
work on we protect the public safety but
for all the people who need our help in
society there's one thing we and
government cannot do we can't love only
people can love and those people have to
be local in your community to be able to
do that
because for the people who need our
health the path recovery is not a
straight line sometimes it's two steps
forward one step back and on that step
back somebody has got to be there to
love them back on that pathway to
success that requires a person that's
not going to come from the government so
we have to have these voluntary
organizations
in our communities to be able to provide
that if we truly want to help our
neighbors who need our help and it is
important to maintaining our system of
self-government that we have these
voluntary organizations because they're
outside of government if we want to talk
about self-government we can't have the
answer always be government it's going
to be other organizations and if you
bear with me a moment I'm gonna read a
quote here from Alexis de Tocqueville
democracy in America Americans of all
ages all conditions all minds constantly
unite not only do they have commercial
and industrial Association in which they
all take part but they also have a
thousand other kinds religious moral
grey futile very general and very
particular immense and very small
Americans use associations to give feats
to found seminaries to build ends to
raise churches to distribute books to
send missionaries on to Antep EADS in
this manner they create hospitals
prisons schools finally if it is a
question of bringing to light a truth or
developing a sentiment with the support
of a great example they associate
everywhere that at the head of a new
undertaking you see the government in
France and a great Lord in England count
on it that you will perceive an
association in the United States in
America I encountered sorts of
associations of which I confess I had no
idea
and I often admire the infinite art with
which the inhabitants of the United
States managed to fix a common goal to
the efforts of many men and to get them
to advance it freely folks are voluntary
organizations in our society are
fundamental and critical to our very
Republic because it gets at that
self-governance outside of the United
States to be able to solve problems and
say not everything needs that government
hammer to be able to be fixed and so we
need to encourage that now as governor I
have the opportunity to do that in a
variety of ways certainly as governor
you can bring people
together and you can set the agenda you
can set the tone
so I attend you know all sorts of
charity functions I actually rent out or
hold dinners give away dinners to
auction dinners we in our
sesquicentennial year our 150th year of
statehood are promoting volunteerism as
part of our overall celebration of our
statehood my wife's got an initiative
called bringing up Nebraska which is
about organizing all of our nonprofits
as well as our state agencies in the
county and so forth in our communities
to be able to leverage all those
resources so we can do a better job
providing those from the families that
need it there's all sorts of things that
we can do to encourage our voluntary
organizations in our society and we have
to to strengthen that very fabric of
civil society and reinforce that
self-governance
does not mean government so those are
the things that we need to think about
as conservatives now one of the things
just as we wrap up here I want to
impress upon you the left is really
really good at incrementalism they are
very patient they get something they
come back the next year and ask for a
little bit more we've got to think along
the same lines we've got to be patient
we've got to be persistent we've got to
think about how we rethink entitlements
around our goals and pushing that
responsibility back to the states where
that responsibility belongs when we're
in power we've got to make sure
government works for the people because
that's how we change that mindset around
what government is all about that we can
actually do a better job delivering
services and bring our cost out at the
same time those two ideas are not
mutually incompatible and we've got to
strengthen our voluntary organizations
those civic organizations that provide
so much service that aren't government
that are part of how we self govern that
has nothing to do with anything that
hasn't involved in the government that's
part of how we start turning the tide
here how we start taming that Leviathan
of big government and bring it back
under
control the way our founders originally
intended thank you for what you all do
as a part of that debate dialogue
Hillsdale is known where people talk
about big ideas and so you all play an
important role in making sure we have
this conversation about how we properly
govern ourselves and make sure we live
up to the fundamental ideas and ideals
that the founders of this republic knew
would make us the greatest country the
world has ever seen god bless you all
for what you do and God bless the United
States of America
and with that I think we might have time
for one or two questions dr. Arnn you're
gonna give me the hook when it's time
right Carrie Adi says okay so obviously
if you have to leave go ahead and leave
if you want to skip class I'll write you
a note afterwards I don't know if it'll
do you any good but do we have any
questions really I did that good job
Explo we've got quit here we go get
questions over here
thank you sir um I wonder at what point
you see government's role in rethinking
entitlements should be entirely given
over to voluntary associations is there
some point where we want to decrease
government's role there so that it's
really done by the fabric of society
yeah I mean so the the extent that we
can do this we absolutely should make it
the most because again getting back to
that point where if you really want to
help people you need to have somebody
love them they gotta have that personal
contact you know Ronald Reagan said we
can't help everybody but everybody can
help somebody so we should be thinking
as much as possible now where does that
line get drawn from a pragmatic
standpoint it's gonna be tough because
we've created such a huge bureaucracy
around this it's gonna be tough there's
a lot of people that have got a lot of
big money stakes involved in this folks
which means they hire lobbyists they
spend a lot of money to make sure that
those entitlements don't go away so it's
gonna be very challenging but the way we
tackle this gets back to that one of the
things I said which is give it back to
the states take it away from the federal
government give it back to the states I
know you all had a conversation about
health care Graham Cassady would have
been a great way to be able to do that
for intricate place now it's not the
system we all would have designed as
conservatives but given where we are
today
Graham caste was a great solution to cap
our liability on Medicaid expansion
because right now folks I don't know if
you know this we have an unlimited
liability for Medicaid expansion today
there is no end of the amount of money
we can spend on this it just goes up and
up and up and so Graham caster would
have capped that and it would have
pushed that money back to the states in
the form of block grants to let us come
up with solutions and how we can solve
that and when we're thinking about
entitlements we need to do that we need
to push them responsibly back to the
States let them design it and be able to
kind of cap what we're spending there so
that we can be successful in managing
our budgets and that that will also
encourage us to involve those civic
organizations that are in our
communities to be able to be part of the
solutions and that's how we can start
bringing them in and so this overall
conversate
and reduce the around reliance on
government so I don't have an exact line
of where we can cut it off and say okay
it's got to be a civic organization not
a government organization but we know
where we're going far to the wrong you
know direct the direction wrong way
toward the government we've got to
reverse that and start heading it back
to our communities to be able to truly
help the people who need our help
[Music]
well what we want to do is make sure
that we're not I mean the first thing is
we don't want to displace the private
marketplace we want to make sure that
our private insurers actually are
insuring the people who can actually
afford to pay for it
so what are some of the ideas around
that and you know if we get the
opportunity you know what are some of
the things well in any business twenty
percent of your customers are probably
driving 80 percent of your expenses so
if we can isolate that group that is
driving our expenses and maybe that's
how you use the the federal government's
money our money to be able to address
those folks that are going to be your
high cost move them out of that pool so
the the rest of the insurance pool is
less expensive you can make it more
affordable for everybody else that's an
example of one of the things we can look
at but ultimately won't want to drive at
is not that the government's paying
insurance premiums but that people can
afford to buy insurance so let's get rid
of some of the mandates that people have
more choice you know in just about every
industry where we have high quality and
low cost we have consumers making
choices we allow consumers to make
expensive decisions around buying a
house and buying a car why should this
be any different we have to drive it
back to the consumers making that
trade-off between what do they want to
pay what do they want to get in return
and that's what's gonna make health care
affordable and ultimately that's how we
can make sure everybody has it
thank you my question is this I'm from
California okay can we get you to come
to our stage and in other words what I'm
thinking is that you do have something
that should be packaged some way where
it's transportable and you can get other
minds even if they're my opposition to
you to understand the logical
reasonability of it and try to get other
states on board like that I think it's
essential if the United States is going
to survive we can't have isolated states
that are doing a good job and everybody
else says well big deal you know we need
to get the public educated too because
as hard as a citizen for me to even
communicate on any kind of a level and
on the federal level or to get ideas you
know to them so I'm wondering maybe you
could work with some of the other
governors that feel like you do and and
and get a quorum going where you can
move around the states and at least
suggest ideas or something like that I
don't know yeah I mean I agree with you
hundred percent of mean it's actually
one of the geniuses of our system is the
federalism that we have 50 states that
can implement ideas and I'm a big
believer in stealing other people's good
ideas and in fact I do work well you
know we've got the Republican Governors
Association and so I work with my
colleagues around sharing best practices
and and so forth that way but you're
exactly right I believe that we and
Nebraska can implement programs that you
can look at in other states and say we
can do the same thing and it might not
be exactly what we do in Nebraska but
that's part of what we should be
thinking about is how again if you push
the responsibility back to the states
let them come up with ideas some will
work some won't but take the ideas at
work and then copy them from other
states so we try to do that all the time
in my administration one of my first
questions is anybody else got this
problem what are they doing to solve it
child welfare for example is one of the
ones that it's a tough nut to crack how
do you provide these services and
frankly I don't know that there's any
state that's doing it well but we go out
and we look to see what our other best
practices and so we try to again I work
with somebody colleagues there's
probably other ways that we can get that
word out there but this is actually
frankly one of them by talking about the
things we're doing in Nebraska that are
unique like our reemployment program
what we've been doing with snap to try
and rethink how we do entitlements to
get the word out there to let other
people think about that to my boss last
question so I'm gonna ask it that fair
you were chief operating officer of TD
Ameritrade and they just doing that and
what you're doing now is that everybody
working for you now is working for the
government how's that different and how
do you cope with it so it is true that
in our divided form of government right
we've got three branches and as the
governor when I put together a budget
it's not really a budget it's more like
a suggestion so I make a recommendation
to the legislature but of course they've
got the purse strings and that's where
you have to work together to be able to
make that happen in fact
I had to veto out some accounting
gimmicks and some tax increases and some
spending in our last budget but it's
actually a lower threshold to override
my veto in Nebraska than it is to
actually break a filibuster so I worked
with the conservative senators to
explain to him here's what we're doing
actually it was a collaborative effort I
said we could take some deep cuts in
these areas or we could do a broad base
cut we talked about how we would manage
these cuts so for example we're talking
about cutting some of our provider rate
pools we have these pools of money that
we pay people like in child Family
Services or Medicaid we said here's how
we're gonna manage these cuts so that
providers don't see a rate cut and we
brought them along to be able to sustain
those vetoes so it's a it's a much more
collaborative you have to it just takes
longer to go through the process than if
you're say a chief operating officer
you're setting a budget and then that's
the budget when it's come to things that
such as really getting this process
improvement going we've really had no
pushback occasionally when we walk into
a department they'll say oh you're here
to fire it so I'm sure you put these
measurements in you're gonna fire us
like no we're actually here to show you
how you can have job satisfaction
because we're going to set goals and
when you reach
you know you're doing a good job can you
imagine the kind of job where you just
processing paperwork all day and you
have no idea whether or not it means
anything or whether you're doing a good
job so as we've been implementing our
reforms frankly and again if you know
anything about Lean Six Sigma you know
it involves the frontline people getting
in together just to come up with the
solutions so we've we've had people you
know at first be a little hesitant but
once you get past that and they see what
the process is really like they're on
board so it is the process is you know
when you're in government it takes
longer you know what we're talking about
changing culture and even in the private
sector it takes years to change a
culture I know we my family's been
through it with the Chicago Cubs they
were the lovable losers and now that
would be another whole 20 minute
presentation talking about that about
how we change that around but you can
change the culture it takes time but we
are doing it in Nebraska to get people
to think differently about how we run
the government so that we can actually
be that organization is operational
operationally excellent that is our goal
we're about operational excellence we're
about delivering better services about
showing cost that's the same thing we
did in a merit rate we were about
operational excellence takes a little
bit longer in government but you can
absolutely do it and that's part of
again getting that second point that's
what we've got to do as conservatives
when we're governing we've got to make
sure we're making government work for
the peoples so we can keep earning their
trust and their votes and get keep
getting sent back so we can keep making
changes well again folks thank you all
very much for having me here today it's
been an honor and a pleasure I very much
appreciate you taking the time dr. Arnn
thank you very much you all have a great
rest of the day a great week